This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加百分号，可在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎来到Look Back at it播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听look back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知晓如何应对的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听learn the hard way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听Love Trapped播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨
some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is. for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s. Before we get started, in this episode, we are going to be talking about some concepts and ideas and experiences that might be a little bit hard to hear, particularly around eating disorders, weight gain, weight loss, and associated topics. Please just take a moment to check in with yourself and decide whether this is what you need to be hearing right now.
我们20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析20多岁的心理学。在我们开始之前，本期节目中，我们将讨论一些概念、想法和经历，听起来可能会有点沉重，特别是围绕饮食失调、体重增加、体重减轻以及相关的话题。请花一点时间自我觉察一下，并决定这是否是你现在需要听的内容。
This episode is still going to be here in a few weeks, a few months. If you want to come back to it when you're in a better place to receive this information, it is obviously your choice, but I thought I would just give you a heads up. Today we are going to be talking about emotional eating. Our relationship with food is so much more psychological than we think it is so much more emotional, so much more intricate and nuanced than just hunger and fullness and nutrients and energy. Food can be used to self-medicate to manage our emotions. It has a biological impact on our mental state.
本期节目在几周、几个月后依然会在这里。如果你想在自己状态更好、能够接受这些信息时再回来听，这当然由你决定，但我还是想先给你提个醒。今天我们要探讨的是情绪性进食。我们与食物的关系比我们想象的要心理化得多，要情绪化得多，比单纯的饥饿、饱腹感、营养和能量要复杂和微妙得多。食物可以被用来自我治疗以管理我们的情绪。它对我们的精神状态有着生物学上的影响。
and I think with a rise in things like diet culture, it's also become really equated with ideas of self-worth and self-esteem such that it's no longer just the thing that we use to fuel ourselves. It has a much more complicated relationship with how we see ourselves and how we process our emotions. I want to be really candid here. I don't think that I personally have ever had a perfect relationship with food. I think right now where I'm at is probably the closest I've ever gotten. And I haven't spoken it much about on the podcast before because it is really vulnerable. But, you know, I grew up in the time of Thinspo and Tumblr. And for a long time, food really controlled my life in an unhealthy way, whereby I was either highly restrictive,
我认为随着饮食文化等事物的兴起，它也真正与自尊和自我价值的观念等同起来，以至于它不再仅仅是我们用来补充能量的东西。它与我们如何看待自己以及我们如何处理情绪有着更加复杂的关系。在这里我想非常坦诚地说。我认为我个人从来没有与食物建立过完美的健康关系。我想我目前达到的状态可能是我有史以来最接近健康的了。以前我在播客里没有怎么谈过这个，因为这真的非常脆弱。但是，你知道，我是伴随着“Thinspo”（瘦身灵感）和Tumblr的时代长大的。在很长一段时间里，食物确实以一种不健康的方式控制了我的生活，导致我要么极端克制，
especially in my teen years, constantly needing to eat the right way, being worried about calories, or on the flip side, I felt completely beholden to food and to my cravings. I never really experienced hunger. I used food as a coping mechanism to elevate my mood or counter my stress or feel emotionally fulfilled when I was lonely or felt rejected. Part of that journey was to do with emotional eating, responding to what I was feeling through consumption rather than self-reflection. And I think I've come to realize that in many ways it has damaged my ability to really listen to my body.
尤其是在我的青少年时期，总是需要以正确的方式进食，担心卡路里，或者在另一方面，我感觉自己完全受制于食物和我的食欲。我从来没有真正体验过饥饿。我把食物当作一种应对机制来提升情绪、对抗压力，或者在感到孤独或被拒绝时寻找心理上的满足。这段心路历程的一部分就与情绪性进食有关，是通过进食来应对我的感受，而不是通过自我反思。我想我渐渐意识到，在许多方面，这损害了我真正倾听身体声音的能力。
It's also brought a lot of shame that I think is still present. Shame that I think doesn't really have a place when it comes to taking care of our bodies, taking care of our vessel, our home. So what I really want this episode to be for you is a guide to unpacking the kind of psychological distinction between emotional and physical. hunger and I want you to be able to see why your own relationship with food may have been impacted by things like diet culture, like social media, like your stress response, like childhood experiences, like emotionally charged events and big life changes. And it's impacted how we see our bodies such that we no longer really know what our bodies need. So in today's episode,
这也带来了很多羞耻感，我认为这种羞耻感至今仍然存在。我认为，当涉及到照顾我们的身体、照顾我们的躯壳、我们的家时，羞耻感其实并没有容身之地。所以我真正希望这期节目能成为你的一份指南，帮你剖析情绪性饥饿与生理性饥饿之间的心理区别；我希望你能明白，为什么你与食物的关系可能受到了饮食文化、社交媒体、压力反应、童年经历、充满情感的事件以及重大生活转折等因素的影响。这已经影响了我们看待身体的方式，以至于我们不再真正了解我们的身体需要什么。所以在今天的节目中，
we are going to break down the very definition of emotional eating. The links to stress and biology and cultural influences. I also want to explore some of the shame that we have towards food, where that comes from, why we feel the need to eat certain foods in particular when things are distressing or when we are bored, and how to recognize that urge. As always, though, this is a show about giving you back your power through information, through psychoeducation, through science. So we're also going to discuss some of the research around kind of the road to quote unquote food freedom, how to control your emotional urge to fuel your body in a way that may not be physically or mentally satisfying.
我们将剖析情绪性进食的确切定义。它与压力、生物学以及文化影响之间的联系。我还想探讨我们对食物的种种羞耻感来自何处、为什么我们在感到痛苦或无聊时会特别想要吃某些食物，以及如何识别这种冲动。不过，和往常一样，这是一个通过信息、心理教育和科学来赋予你力量的节目；所以我们还将讨论一些围绕所谓“食物自由”之路的研究，探讨如何控制你的情绪冲动，以一种在生理上或心理上可能并不满足的方式来为身体补充能量。
And also kind of what the actual deal is with, you know, intuitive eating. I had my doubts around intuitive eating. I get asked to talk about it all the time. And this felt like the perfect episode to have a discussion around, you know, what that kind of. of that kind of way of eating, that way of almost dieting really does for our bodies. So there is a lot to cover and there will also be some resources in the episode description if you need them. I know that this topic can sometimes be kind of heavy but we're here to inform so please just make sure that you're in a good place to hear this without further ado. Let's get into the psychological underpinnings
以及关于直觉饮食到底是怎么回事。我曾经对直觉饮食抱有疑虑。总有人让我谈谈这个。我觉得这是展开讨论的绝佳契机，聊聊那种进食方式、那种近乎节食的方式究竟能为我们的身体带来什么。所以我们要涵盖的内容很多，如果你需要的话，节目简介中也会提供一些资源。我知道这个话题有时可能会显得有些沉重，但我们的目的是提供资讯，所以请确保你处于一个良好的状态来收听此内容。闲话少说。让我们深入探讨
behind why we emotionally eat. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们情绪性进食背后的心理根源。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你抛开那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们大错特错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们在这个世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent，可在I-Hart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么鬼关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过那段时光的。其中还包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时准备在节目中谈论快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。现在我们还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听look back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我将带来自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与众多杰出的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会深陷追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now.
这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。和我，科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的IHeart RadioAPP，搜索learning a hard way并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破获此案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So what actually is emotional eating, because it's a lot more than just kind of eating your feelings, which I think is definitely a phrase we need to retire.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听Love Trapped播客。那么，到底什么是情绪性进食呢？因为这远不止是所谓的“用食物宣泄情绪”——我认为这绝对是一个我们需要淘汰的短语。
It feels very, very much reminiscent of those early 2000s, mean girl-esque movies where someone is shamed for just choosing to eat what they like when emotional eating is actually so much more than responding to what your body craves and fulfilling that need. I want that to be really clear. Emotional eating isn't just the opposite of eating quote unquote unhealthy or eating foods that society may deem as bad every now and again. Emotional eating is not just having a poor diet. It occurs when we eat for reasons other than hunger or physical necessity.
这感觉非常、非常让人想起2000年代初期那些刻薄女孩风格的电影，在那里，有人因为选择吃自己喜欢的东西而感到羞耻，而实际上，情绪性进食远不止是对身体渴望的反应并满足这种需求。我希望这一点非常明确。情绪性进食并不只是吃所谓的“不健康”食物或偶尔吃一些社会可能认为是不好的食物的反面。情绪性进食不仅仅是饮食习惯不好。它发生在我们的进食原因并非出于饥饿或生理需求时。
It's where we use food. as a way to cope with difficult feelings, uncomfortable feelings, or as a distraction to some deeper problem that's bothering us, maybe it's bothering us consciously, but more often than not, it's unconscious, it's subconscious. So emotional eating is a form of emotional regulation that becomes an automatic behavior in response to stress rather than using our mental coping skills. And although there's been some studies, including one conducted in 2016, that sometimes sees emotional eating in response to positive emotions and positive moments, I think it's mainly in relation to the moments when we are really struggling.
这是我们使用食物。作为应对困难情绪、不舒服情绪的一种方式，或者是作为转移注意力的一种手段，来应对困扰我们的某个更深层次的问题——也许它在意识层面困扰着我们，但更多时候它是无意识的、潜意识的。所以情绪性进食是一种情绪调节的形式，它在面对压力时会变成一种自动的行为反应，而不是使用我们的心理应对技巧。尽管已经有一些研究（包括2016年进行的一项研究）发现有时情绪性进食是对积极情绪和积极时刻的反应，但我认为它主要还是与我们真正苦苦挣扎的时刻有关。
And the kind of shame and guilt that comes with that. So here are some examples of how this might show up in your life, how we see emotional eating in our everyday kind of dietary behaviors. Say, for example, you've just gone through a really terrible breakup. and you use food for comfort. You're really overly stressed at work, you're worried about money, you use food as a distraction, you're feeling lonely or disconnected. Food becomes a way to feel fulfilled physically when mentally or socially,
以及随之而来的那种羞耻感和内疚感。所以，以下是这可能会如何在你的生活中表现出来的一些例子，也就是我们在日常饮食行为中如何看待情绪性进食。比如，假设你刚刚经历了一次非常糟糕的分手。而你用食物来寻求安慰。你在工作中压力巨大，担心金钱，你把食物当作转移注意力的工具，你感到孤独或与世隔绝。食物成为了一种在精神或社交上、
you are quite dissatisfied. There are so many other examples, each of them really, you know, very much unique to us as individuals. And sometimes really extreme. There was two researchers in 2012 who even conducted a study on emotional eating in the wake of a natural disaster. They assessed eating behavior in Christchurch, New Zealand. So our neighbors to the south, back in 2011, I believe they were struck by a really major earthquake. And the results of this study showed that women in particular reported an increase in overeating after the earthquake,
你相当不满意时，用来获得生理满足感的方式。还有很多其他的例子，每一个对我们个人来说都确实非常独特。有时甚至相当极端。2012年曾有两位研究人员甚至在自然灾害发生后对情绪性进食进行了一项研究。他们评估了新西兰基督城的饮食行为。也就是我们的南方邻居，早在2011年，我记得他们遭遇了一场非常大的地震。这项研究的结果表明，女性在地震后尤其报告了暴饮暴食的增加，
especially when they had experienced high levels of earthquake related to stress, showing how food is not just fuel, food is a way for us to process or sometimes suppress emotions. So I think no matter this scenario, the main premise is that in these situations, food loses its original purpose as something to sustain us and becomes a tool to kind of somewhat fill an emotional void that we are not. not capable of recognizing or managing in the moment. And it's not just you. It's not just you who is struggling with this problem.
特别是当她们经历了高水平的与地震相关的压力时，这表明食物不仅仅是燃料，食物是我们处理甚至压抑情绪的一种方式。所以我认为无论在什么情况下，主要的前提是，在这些情况下，食物失去了它作为维持我们生存的东西的原始本领，而变成了一种工具，用来在某种程度上填补我们在当时无力识别或管理的感情空虚。而且不只是你。并不是只有你一个人在与这个问题作斗争。
The American Psychological Association estimates that around 33% of adult Americans are overeating or eating foods that they crave when they are stressed or to distract from stress. It's interesting because sometimes people go the other way. You know, during stressful scenarios, they lose all of their appetite. and they completely deny themselves food, which just kind of goes to show how eating behavior is so linked to our emotional state, but also both of those tendencies, the tendencies to perhaps overeat or eat particular foods,
美国心理学协会估计，大约有33%的成年美国人在感到压力时，或者为了转移对压力的注意力，会暴饮暴食或吃自己渴望的食物。有趣的是，有时人们会走向另一个极端。你知道，在充满压力的情境下，他们会失去所有的食欲。并完全拒绝进食，这恰恰说明了饮食行为与我们的情绪状态联系得有多么紧密，但同时，这两种倾向——也许是暴饮暴食或吃特定食物的倾向，
and then that loss of appetite or that kind of denying yourself, sustenance, denying yourself food, both of those tendencies are not their own disorder, rather they are a symptom of disordered eating. And disordered eating is what can escalate into an eating disorder like binge eating disorder like anorexia or bulimia, but it's typically associated with eating at a regular times, being really strict with your food choices or obsessive thoughts about food, finding that you can't stop eating, feelings of guilt and shame towards your eating habits, which is often associated with labeling some foods as good and some foods as bad. I think the increasing tendency that diet culture has pushed on us to see
然后那种食欲不振或拒绝进食、拒绝摄入营养的倾向——这两种倾向本身并不是一种独立的失调，而是饮食失调的一种症状。饮食失调可能会升级为进食障碍，比如暴食症、神经性厌食症或贪食症，但它通常表现为进食时间不规律、对食物的选择极其严格，或者对食物有强迫性的想法，发现自己无法停下来，对自己的饮食习惯感到内疚和羞耻，这通常与将某些食物贴上“好”标签、将某些食物贴上“坏”标签有关。我认为饮食文化强加给我们的这种日益强烈的趋势——把
certain foods as pure and even virtuous and other foods as sinful or dirty or bad is so problematic and such a huge disaster for our relationship with food to be able to acknowledge that it is fuel. It is one of the primary sources of life. Nowadays it's so much more than that, which is I think. why many of us see it as something more emotional, something more mental, because suddenly it has all of these really weird links to very intangible ideas of good and bad. Food is a lot more plentiful, but it's also a lot more complicated. And so we use it to self-sove, we use it to punish
某些食物视为纯洁甚至高尚的，而将其他食物视为罪恶的、肮脏的或糟糕的——是如此之具破坏性，对我们与食物的关系来说更是一场巨大的灾难，让我们无法承认食物本质上就是燃料。它是生命的主要来源之一。如今它被赋予了远超于此的意义，我想这就是为什么我们许多人认为它包含更多情绪、更多心理因素的原因，因为突然之间它与所有这些关于好坏的极其怪异的无形观念挂钩了。食物变得更加丰富，但也变得更加复杂。因此我们用它来自我慰藉，有时我们用它来惩罚
ourselves at times. We kind of use our consumption of certain foods as a proxy for our self-worth, which is why we observe those eating disorders like anorexia. Yes. there is this preoccupation with weight loss and body image and thinness, but it's also the use of food to test self-discipline because maybe we can't control what else is going on within our lives, but we can control what we eat. Something I always like to remind myself and you guys as well is that food does not have a moral label or a moral value. The foods you eat do not determine your worth as a human. It's literally an inanimate object. How can something inanimate be good or bad, it's just food. It has no deeper attachment to who you are, to what your value is.
我们自己。我们某种程度上将某些食物的摄入作为我们自尊的替代指标，这就是为什么我们会观察到像神经性厌食症这样的进食障碍。是的。这里存在着对减重、身体形象和纤瘦的执念，但它也是利用食物来测试自我纪律的一种手段，因为也许我们无法控制生活中发生的其他事情，但我们可以控制我们吃什么。我总是喜欢提醒自己和你们大家的一点是，食物没有道德标签或道德价值。你吃的食物并不能决定你作为人类的价值。它字面上就是一个无生命的物体。一个无生命的东西怎么能分好坏呢，它只是食物。它与你是谁、你的价值如何没有任何更深层的依恋。
And yet we have been convinced that to eat some foods is to be hurting our body, is to not have self-discipline, is to not care about our well-being. So of course, we have begun to treat it as a way to self-punish or to mediate our emotions. I think the easiest way we can identify when we're eating from a place of needing emotional comfort or fulfillment is by noticing the difference between physical hunger and emotional hunger. So physical hunger develops over time, whilst emotional hunger comes on really suddenly, often in response to some kind of trigger that causes you to become stressed or overwhelmed. So you're looking for something to kind of mediate those emotions to make you feel better.
然而，我们却被灌输了这样一种观念：吃某些食物就是在伤害我们的身体，就是在缺乏自律，就是不关心我们的健康。所以理所当然地，我们开始把食物当作自我惩罚或调节情绪的一种方式。我认为，要想识别我们是否是为了寻求情绪安慰或满足而进食，最简单的方法就是注意生理性饥饿和情绪性饥饿之间的区别。因此，生理性饥饿是逐渐产生的，而情绪性饥饿则突然来袭，通常是对某种导致你感到压力或不堪重负的触发因素的反应。所以你在寻找某种东西来调解这些情绪，让你感觉好一点。
When we are physically hungry as well, we notice being full and we take it as a cue to stop eating. Whereas when we're experiencing emotional hunger, we really don't feel completely full until after we've stopped, until the aftermath of whatever we've just eaten and we don't feel well, we feel sick, we wish that we had kind of stopped earlier, we don't feel like we've actually given our body the proper nutrients that maybe it deserves. Physical hunger is often predictable. If we haven't eaten in the last four hours or so, maybe longer, we know that our body is going to start craving nutrients and energy, it's going to start grumbling, whereas emotional hunger is just going to happen whenever, wherever. The reason for this is that food means more to our body
当我们感到生理上饥饿时，我们会注意到自己饱了，并以此作为停止进食的信号。而当我们体验到情绪性饥饿时，直到我们停下来、直到我们刚刚吃完东西的余波过去、直到我们感觉不好、感到恶心、希望自己早点停下来之前，我们真的不会觉得自己彻底吃饱了，我们不会觉得自己真正给予了身体本应得到的适当营养。生理性饥饿通常是可以预测的。如果我们过去四个小时左右没有吃东西，也许时间更长，我们就知道身体会开始渴望营养和能量，开始咕咕叫，而情绪性饥饿则随时随地都可能发生。其原因在于，食物对我们的身体而言意义重大，
than just nutrients and energy. It's cultural, it's mental, it's social. We see that in how food is a massive part of how every single culture in the world celebrates or connects. We see that in how different foods make us feel a different way. The fact that we have concepts such as comfort foods, the foods that elicit some kind of emotional reaction of either nostalgia or warmth or contentment. And then it comes down to things like taste and flavor and the impact of certain ingredients or contents, how they impact our brain, particularly through their influence on our hormones and our neurotransmitters. Essentially, both of those things are the building blocks for our everyday emotional state. So from a biological point, we all
不仅仅是营养和能量。它是文化的、心理的、社会的。我们在世界上每一种文化如何通过食物进行庆祝或建立联系中看到了这一点。我们在不同的食物如何让我们产生不同的感受中看到了这一点。事实上，我们拥有诸如“安慰食物”这样的概念，即能够引发某种怀旧、温暖或满足等情绪反应的食物。然后它归结为诸如品味、风味以及某些成分或内容的影响等事情，它们如何影响我们的大脑，特别是通过它们对我们的荷尔蒙和神经递质的影响。本质上，这两者都是我们日常情绪状态的基石。所以从生物学的角度来看，我们都
know that we need to eat to sustain our physical well-being, but currently from all the recent studies conducted on this, we also know that it has a lot to do with pleasure. All acts of eating increases dopamine in our brains, and it lights up our reward system. But that is especially the case when we eat foods that are high in fat and sugar. Because if we think about this evolutionarily, those foods are often the highest in energy, such that they are more likely to provide us with those fat stores that previously were crucial for our survival. So our brains will create cues, internal cues, pleasure cues, to motivate us to consume these more by making us feel happier in association.
知道我们需要进食来维持生理健康，但目前从最近对该课题的所有研究中，我们也知道这与快乐有很大关系。所有的进食行为都会增加我们大脑中的多巴胺，并点亮我们的奖赏系统。特别是当我们吃那些高脂肪和高糖的食物时，情况更是如此。因为如果我们从进化的角度来思考，这些食物往往含有最高的能量，因此它们更有可能为我们提供那些以前对我们生存至关重要的脂肪储存。因此，大脑会创造出内部线索、快乐线索，通过让我们产生更快乐的联想，来激励我们更多地消费这些食物。
So food has this inherent impact on our brain through its impact on the dopamine system, which is responsible for the release of things like dopamine, of course, but also serotonin or oxytocin, and this is the biological basis for emotional eating. Consuming foods in order to improve our mood through that biological relationship rather than for hunger or some physical advantage. For example, when we are feeling bored, we often gravitate towards food that offer a really rich flavor profile, or we'll eat more not because of actual taste or that biological impact down the line, that because the act of eating in itself is a task that can keep our mind
所以食物通过其对多巴胺系统的影响，对我们的大脑产生了一种内在的影响，多巴胺系统负责释放诸如多巴胺等物质，当然还有血清素或催产素，这就是情绪性进食的生物学基础。为了通过这种生物学关系改善我们的情绪而摄取食物，而不是为了饥饿或某种生理优势。例如，当我们感到无聊时，我们常常倾向于那些提供丰富风味特征的食物，或者我们会吃得更多，这并不是因为实际的味道或长远来看的生物学影响，而是因为进食行为本身是一项可以通过咀嚼、品尝、将东西放进嘴里、吞咽来让我们的头脑保持娱乐的任务，这是一项体力活动。它给我们提供了一些事情可做。
entertained by chewing, by tasting, by putting things in our mouth, by swallowing, that is a physical activity. It gives us something to do. When we feel stressed, though, we often crave things that are high in carbs, high in sugar, because stress depletes our energy through the excessive release of things like cortisol and adrenaline that puts pressure on our body. So we want to build back up those energy stores. And then when we're sad, when we're heartbroken, we often have less of an appetite due to that distress and that deep hurt. So our bodies want to get the most energy from consuming as little food as possible. That means high fat, high energy, ice cream, chocolate, very much what we would call the heartbreak diet of Hollywood, what we see
然而，当我们感到压力时，我们通常渴望高碳水、高糖的食物，因为压力会通过过度释放诸如皮质醇和肾上腺素等物质来消耗我们的能量，这给我们的身体带来了压力。所以我们想要重建这些能量储备。然后当我们悲伤时，当我们心碎时，由于这种痛苦和深层的伤害，我们的食欲往往会降低。所以我们的身体希望通过摄入尽可能少的食物来获取最多的能量。这意味着高脂肪、高能量，冰淇淋、巧克力，非常符合我们在好莱坞电影中看到的所谓“失重心碎饮食”。但它可能在科学上也是正确的。我们渴望这些食物，
in movies. But it's probably also scientifically correct. We crave these foods. because of an inconsistent release of the hunger hormone. And after a period of intense heartbreak, that means that we are more inclined to go for those sugary snacks without really understanding our hunger. A lot of these examples, as you may have gathered, have to do with attempts to rein in our stress response. And that is because the act of eating certain food groups, certain foods, and our experiences of anxiety are causally related. They're correlated in quite a multiple. multidirectional way. So firstly, according to Harvard Medical School, the foods we eat actually can mimic some of the symptoms of anxiety or stress or even panic attacks that we normally associate with
是因为饥饿激素的不规律释放。在一阵强烈的心碎之后，这意味着我们更容易在不真正理解饥饿感的情况下选择那些含糖零食。正如你可能已经收集到的那样，这些例子中有许多都与试图控制我们的压力反应有关。这是因为摄取某些食物群、某些食物的行为与我们的焦虑体验之间存在因果关系。它们以一种多方向的方式相互关联。首先，根据哈佛医学院的说法，我们吃的食物实际上可以模仿我们在高压时期通常与之联系在一起的焦虑、压力甚至恐慌发作的一些症状，特别是高糖或高咖啡因的食物。所以，虽然我们可能会寻找某种我们认为能在高度焦虑时让我们感觉好受一点的食物，但它往往会产生反效果，让情况变得更糟。
high periods of stress, especially foods high in sugar or caffeine. So whilst we might search for some type of food we think is going to make us feel better in a time of heightened anxiety, it kind of has the counter effect, makes it worse. But it's not just, what that food provides, like we spoke about with emotional eating in response to boredom, sometimes the physical act of consuming something or not consuming something using food to provide an emotional catharsis to symbolically act to fill your stomach and feel like you're fulfilling your emotional needs, that is so satisfying and it causes us to emotionally eat. And when we talk about the stress response, the experiences of fear, some studies have shown that when we eat, we provide a cue to our brain that we are safe.
但这不仅仅是食物所提供的，就像我们谈到为应对无聊而进行的情绪性进食一样，有时摄入某物或不摄入某物的生理行为——利用食物提供情感宣泄，象征性地填满你的胃，感觉自己正在满足你的情感需求——是如此令人满意，并导致我们情绪性进食。当我们谈论压力反应、恐惧体验时，一些研究表明，当我们进食时，我们向大脑提供了一个我们是安全的信号。你知道，如果我们正处于战斗或逃离模式中，试图逃离某种威胁，我们是不会停下来吃零食的。当我们感到危险时，我们的食欲会受到抑制。我们专注于克服我们正在经历的、我们所恐惧的任何事情。
You know, if we are actively in fight or flight mode trying to escape some threat, we're not going to stop for a snack. Our appetite is suppressed when we feel danger. And we are focused on overcoming whatever we are experiencing, whatever we are fearful of. but when we eat, when we force our bodies to consume something, to sit, to have a meal or a snack, our brain goes, okay, well, we can't be in immediate danger because otherwise we wouldn't be doing this right now. We wouldn't be doing this. So we must be okay. It gives your brain a cue to calm down, to stop panicking. So that is another way that stress is mediated by what we choose to eat when we choose to eat it, not from a place of physical hunger, but an emotional need.
但是当我们进食时，当我们强迫身体去摄取某样东西、去坐下来、去吃一顿饭或吃点零食时，我们的大脑就会想，好吧，我们不可能处于即时危险之中，否则我们现在就不会这么做了。我们不会这么做。所以我们一定没事。这给了你的大脑一个信号，让它平静下来，停止恐慌。所以，这就是通过我们选择吃什么、我们何时选择吃食物来调解压力的另一种方式，这并非出于生理饥饿，而是出于情感需求。
You know, what I think that scientific explanation tells us what I think is most crucial to take from this is that we can't really blame ourselves for using food to self-medicate or regulate our emotions, nor can we just see it as an us problem, that we lack discipline, that we're weak. Therefore, I think what happens when we take on that perspective is that we self-inflict a lot of shame around the foods that we consume when we're sad or we're bored or we're overwhelmed or we're stressed because the nature of this is that this habit comes from a lot of factors outside of our control. Some of them are just innately biological, like our stress response. Others are societal and cultural and a lot of them are to do with diet culture and how our health system
你知道，我认为科学解释告诉我们的、我认为最需要从中汲取的最关键点是，我们不能真正责怪自己利用食物来自我治疗或调节情绪，我们也不能仅仅把它看作是我们自己的问题，认为我们缺乏纪律、我们很软弱。因此，我认为当我们持有这种观点时，我们会围绕那些在我们悲伤、无聊、不堪重负或压力大时所消耗的食物产生大量的羞耻感，因为这种习惯的本质来自于许多我们无法控制的因素。其中一些纯粹是生物学上的，比如我们的压力反应。另一些则是社会的和文化的，其中很多都与饮食文化以及我们的医疗系统
approaches things like weight and things like calories and things like energy intake. Our current approach to food, especially in a lot of Western societies, has become increasingly focused on restriction or focused on, you know, nutritional and energy intake, on BMI and what is and is not a healthy weight, as well as kind of, you know, alongside that, as we see social media grow a whole series of trend or fad diets that come and go. But those diets are really all kind of telling us the same thing. There is a right way to eat and if you are not doing it this way, you're doing it wrong. It tells us that what we choose to put in our bodies needs to be carefully controlled, whether it's something like the keto diet or intermittent fasting or a raw food diet,
如何处理体重、卡路里和能量摄入等问题有关。我们目前对待食物的方法，尤其是在许多西方社会，越来越专注于限制，或者专注于营养和能量摄入，专注于BMI以及什么是健康体重什么不是健康体重，以及伴随而来的，随着社交媒体的发展，出现了一系列来来去去的潮流或风靡一时的节食法。但这些节食法实际上都在告诉我们同一件事：有一种正确的进食方式，如果你不这样吃，你就是在用错误的方式吃。它告诉我们需要仔细控制放进身体的东西，无论是生酮饮食、间歇性禁食还是生食饮食，
whatever it may be, even a juice cleanse. And you know what that does? It puts us at war with food. It completely damages and disrupts our relationship and our perception of what food is as something that needs to be regulated rather than as fuel, rather than as one of the main sources of life, alongside, you know, it's water, air, and food. Those are the three things that we really need. And I think it's really interesting because you never see someone controlling how much water they drink or trying to stop how much they breathe. But we do have this intense feeling that food needs to be disciplined. Whereas these other sources of life, we don't have that feeling. We don't feel like there's a problem.
无论它是什么，甚至是一场果汁排毒。你知道这会产生什么影响吗？它让我们与食物陷入交战状态。它彻底破坏和干扰了我们对食物的关系和感知，把食物视为需要被规范的东西，而不是视为燃料，而不是视为生命的主要来源之一——除了水、空气和食物之外。这三样东西是我们真正需要的。我觉得这很有趣，因为你从来没见过有人去控制自己喝多少水，或者试图阻止自己呼吸多少次。但我们确实有这种强烈的直觉，觉得食物需要被管束。然而对于其他这些生命源泉，我们却没有这种感觉。我们不觉得有什么问题。
When we feel made to put something on a pedestal like that, that is the easiest way to get something to control you. when we are taught to avoid something like certain foods, the more you want them, because they feel more important, they feel more elusive. And so when we face something like intense emotions, a lot of stress, and our impulse control is lessened because we're trying to navigate so much else, the first thing you're going to do, you're going to go and eat those foods that have previously been off limits to you. You are going to push back against the same. restriction that you have been imposing on yourself, you're not going to be aware of your appetite and you'll overeat and then afterwards you'll probably feel shame. And you'll feel that shame not
当我们感到被迫把某样东西捧上神坛时，这是让那样东西控制你的最简单的方法。当我们被教导要去避免某样东西，比如某些食物时，你就会越想要它们，因为它们感觉更重要、更虚幻。因此，当我们面对像强烈情绪、巨大压力这样难以驾驭的状况，并且由于我们需要应对的事情太多而导致冲动控制力下降时，你首先要做的就是去吃那些以前被禁止的食物。你会去反抗一直强加给自己的那种限制。
because you deserve to feel shame, but because there is so much information coming from so many sources telling you that if you binge eat, if you eat a certain food, that makes you an unhealthy person, that makes you a bad person, that eating that food is bad. And all your brain is actually trying to do in that moment is just emotionally regular. It's just trying to get you back to a safe mental place. I think part of understanding this is acknowledging that your environment is going to impact behaviours like diet based on what we've been convinced is normal or good for us. And social media is part of that environment. So we really need to de-influence ourselves a little bit when it comes to managing our emotional eating. And the best thing,
你将无法意识到自己的食欲，你会暴饮暴食，然后事后你可能会感到羞耻。你会感到羞耻，不是因为你活该感到羞耻，而是因为有太多的信息来自太多的渠道，告诉你如果你暴食、如果你吃了某种食物，这就让你成为了一个不健康的人，这就让你成为了一个坏人，吃那个食物是坏事。而你大脑在那一刻真正试图做的，只是进行情绪调节。它只是试图让你回到一个安全的精神状态。我认为理解这一点的一部分是承认你的环境会影响诸如饮食之类的行为，这基于我们被灌输认为是正常或对我们有益的东西。而社交媒体正是这种环境的一部分。所以在管理我们的情绪性进食时，我们确实需要稍微“去影响”一下自己。而最好的做法是，
for you to do in that moment is to realize that what someone else is doing, what someone else is saying on TikTok, you know, whatever's in there, what I eat in a day video, is probably not going to be right for you. There's always going to be some fad diet or craze or new way to fuel your body or lose weight and that leads us to form an unhealthy relationship with food, one that is not based on feeding our body with what it needs, but intertwined with things like our self-worth, our self-esteem, our sense of value. It's more based on our mood, particularly how we use food once again to make us feel better or make us feel worse depending on how we're feeling in the moment. That's why we emotionally eat. We feel like eating is no longer this natural thing.
你在那一刻能做的事就是意识到别人的做法，别人在TikTok上说的话——无论里面有什么，比如“我一天吃什么”的视频——可能并不适合你。总会存在某种减肥风潮、狂热或为身体补充能量的新方法，这导致我们与食物形成了一种不健康的关系，这种关系不是基于用身体所需的东西来滋养身体，而是与我们的自尊、自我价值感交织在一起。它更多地基于我们的情绪，特别是我们如何再次利用食物来让我们感觉更好或更糟，这取决于我们此刻的感觉。这就是为什么我们情绪性进食。我们觉得进食不再是一件自然的事情。
It's this has this bigger, deeper, deeper role, has this bigger, deeper meat. rather than just its normal natural purpose to fuel our bodies. I want to state again, I know I just spoke about it, but there really shouldn't be any shame around this if this is a behavior that you find yourself engaging in. Like I said, it's something that I've acknowledged I do quite a bit, and I used to think that meant I was weak, or that I didn't care about my body, that I should have had more control.
它扮演了一个更大、更深的角色，有了更大、更深的意义，而不仅仅是为身体提供能量的正常自然目的。我想再次声明，我知道我刚才已经说过这点了，但如果你发现自己正在做出这种行为，这周围真的不应该有任何羞耻感。就像我说的，这是我已经承认自己经常做的一件事，我过去常常认为这意味着我很软弱，或者我不关心自己的身体，我本应该有更多的控制力。
And what I realized now is that that was really the influence of diet culture, being the angry little kind of devil on my shoulder. You know, this tendency comes from so many things outside of our control, but they make us feel like food controls us, makes us feel like what we're putting in our body is necessary for handling our emotions. And that can have a lot of impacts. You know, emotional eating can have really distressing effects by leading to feelings of guilt, but it can also make us feel really ill or it can give us a big sugar crash a few hours later. It can leave us feeling drained. As one nutritionist put it in her article about this subject, which I'll link in the description, it's really fascinating. One of the issues with emotional
我现在意识到，这其实是饮食文化的影响，就像我肩头那个愤怒的小恶魔。你知道，这种倾向源于许多我们无法控制的事情，但它们让我们觉得食物在控制我们，让我们觉得我们放进体内的东西是应对情绪所必需的。这会产生很多影响。你知道，情绪性进食会带来令人沮丧的后果，导致内疚感，但它也可能让我们感到身体很不舒服，或者在几小时后导致严重的血糖骤降。它会让我们感到筋疲力尽。正如一位营养师在她关于这个主题的文章中所说的那样（我会在简介中附上链接），这真的非常迷人。情绪性进食的问题之一是
eating is that it affects, of course, how you feel physically, especially when we overeat because it reduces our energy levels, it can cause headaches, it generally just causes some discomfort. And we're not really resolving the problem, so we're just kind of at a loss loss. So how can we have that more intuitive relationship with the things we're putting in our body and notice the emotional triggers or causes of our dietary behaviors. How can we remove food as a coping mechanism and replace it with strategies that are probably more productive and sustainable in the long run that are going to leave you just feeling better? Well, all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
它当然会影响你的身体感受，尤其是当我们吃得过饱时，因为它会降低我们的能量水平，引起头痛，通常只会带来一些不适。而且我们并没有真正解决问题，所以我们有点不知所措。那么，我们如何才能与放进体内的食物建立更直观的关系，并注意到饮食行为背后的情绪触发因素或原因呢？我们如何才能消除食物作为应对机制的作用，并用从长远来看可能更具生产力和可持续性、能让你感觉更好的策略取而代之？好了，所有这些以及更多内容，都在这段简短的广告之后。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经深信植物油具有天然的炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。即 I-Heart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。其中还包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）做客的节目，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为犯罪。还有快克。我随时都能聊聊84年的快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客，
Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
《从头学起》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《从头学起》中，就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Let's get one thing straight and clear. Right now. Sometimes you've had a rough day. And that just really calls for some meat parades, some pizza, an iceberg, some ice cream. There is nothing wrong with that. You don't need to feel guilt about wanting a certain food. As long as it's not masking and underlying emotional need that you're not fulfilling.
这件事绝不算完。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。让我们开门见山，把话说清楚。此时此刻。有时你度过了糟糕的一天。这真的需要吃点肉类大餐、披萨、冰山生菜或者一些冰淇淋。这完全没有问题。当你渴望某种食物时，你不需要感到内疚。只要它不是在掩盖你尚未满足的潜在情感需求。
but food can be really comforting and maybe the exact thing that you need in that moment to energize yourself to restore those levels. We also naturally experience cravings for certain foods that don't have an emotional basis, even if they are psychological. And I want to explain that a little bit further. So cravings are an intense, specific desire for a certain type of food, and it's in response to needing a certain kind of nourishment that our bodies are maybe not getting, but they also come from our environment,
但食物确实能带来极大的慰藉，也许正是你那一刻急需的东西，能为你补充能量，恢复状态。我们也会自然而然地渴望某些没有情感基础的食物，即使它们带有心理因素。我想对此做进一步的解释。所以，所谓的渴望是对某种特定食物的一种强烈、具体的追求，这是为了回应身体可能没有得到的某种营养需求，但它们也源于我们的环境，
like advertisements which are deliberately created in a specific way to target you, to make you want something, to make you buy it. So sometimes that can get confusing because we don't actually know what our body is needing. We are being queued by our environment. We do have those emotional needs, and sometimes our body just needs that nourishment.
比如广告，它们是经过精心设计的，旨在针对你，让你渴望某样东西，让你去购买它。所以有时这会让人感到困惑，因为我们实际上并不知道身体需要什么。我们正受到环境的暗示。我们的确有那些情感需求，有时我们的身体确实需要那种营养。
It's kind of impossible, right? You know, on one side, the side of diet culture, we're being influenced to always make perfect decisions towards food as if there is actually a date, definition of perfect or that means anything. And then on the other side, this mass marketing side, they're trying to get you to buy that burger to buy that chocolate bar. Those constant opposing narratives makes it so once again, food is no longer just food. So how do we ignore all of that? How do we tap into what our bodies actually need? And what is the role of emotional eating in that
这简直是不可能的，对吧？你知道，一方面，在饮食文化的这一端，我们受到影响，总是对食物做出完美的决定，就好像真的有一个“完美”的明确定义，或者这意味着什么。然后另一方面，在群众营销这一端，他们试图让你去买那个汉堡，去买那块巧克力。这些不断对立的论调使得食物再次不仅仅是食物。那么我们如何忽略所有这些呢？我们如何挖掘身体真正需要的东西？而情绪性进食在其中扮演了什么角色
equation. Firstly, I don't think that demonising certain foods or restrictive eating is going to help you at all, especially if what you're struggling with is emotional eating. It just doesn't work for most people because A, it assumes that your behavior is due to a lack of self-control, therefore it's something that you need to restrict, which just is not the case. B, you're using food to fight an emotional problem. And so it's the emotional problem that we need to work on, not the actual food consumption. So restricting is only going to elevate that emotional stress because it's just one more thing to manage, one more thing to control. Eating may feel good in the moment. Restricting may feel like you're doing something, but the feelings that triggered you to emotionally eat are still going to be there.
等式的一部分。首先，我认为妖魔化某些食物或限制饮食对你毫无帮助，特别是如果你正在与情绪性进食作斗争的话。这对大多数人来说根本不管用，因为 A，它假设你的行为是由于缺乏自控力，因此这是你需要克制的事情，但事实并非如此。B，你在用食物来对抗一个情感问题。所以我们需要解决的是情感问题，而不是实际的食物消耗。因此，克制只会增加这种情感压力，因为它只是又一件需要管理的事情，又一件需要控制的事情。进食在当下可能会感觉很好。克制可能会让你觉得自己正在做点什么，但触发你情绪性进食的感觉依然存在。
And finally, demonizing imposes shame. When we think that we've slipped up, we get stuck in the shame cycle of, why did I do that? I feel so guilty. I have no self-control. And rather than just realizing that there's a lot more going on there than just self-discipline, maybe you're lacking the deeper coping skills and you just don't have them yet. What you're really doing is just making yourself feel once again guilt. You're making yourself feel guilty for something that perhaps you've only just started to recognize something that comes from a lot of deeper factors that is going to take work. And I think it's just identifying that you can cope in a way that's going to leave you feeling better in all facets and areas of your life, not just by reducing
最后，妖魔化会带来羞耻感。当我们觉得自己犯了错时，就会陷入“我为什么会那样做？我感到很内疚。我一点自控力都没有”的羞耻循环中。与其意识到这背后有很多比单纯的自律更复杂的原因，也许你只是缺乏更深层的应对技巧，而你现在还掌握。你实际上在做的，只是再次让自己感到内疚。你为一件可能才刚开始认识到的事情感到内疚，这源于许多更深层的因素，需要付出努力去解决。我认为这只是去确认你可以用一种能在生活的方方面面都让你感觉更好的方式来应对，而不仅仅是通过减少
that current feeling, but feeling more capable of handling all of those future situations where you're going to be stressed, you're going to be sad, you're going to be tired, and food doesn't have to be your only solution. So in terms of overcoming navigating emotional eating, the first thing we really need to do is identify our emotional triggers. The biggest one is without a doubt, stress. When we experience chronic stress, as is so often in our 20s when we got a hundred whole lot of things on our plate, financial stress, relationship stress, career stress, all of that and more. Your body produces high levels of the stress hormone known as cortisol.
当前的感觉，而是让自己更有能力应对未来所有那些你会感到压力、悲伤、疲惫的时刻，而食物不必成为你唯一的解决方案。因此，就克服和应对情绪性进食而言，我们真正需要做的第一件事是识别我们的情绪触发因素。毫无疑问，最大的一个触发因素就是压力。当我们经历长期压力时（这在我们的20多岁时非常常见，当时我们手头堆满了成百上千的事情：经济压力、恋爱压力、职业压力等等），你的身体会产生高水平的压力激素，也就是皮质醇。
So cortisol triggers cravings for salty, sweet, fatty foods, foods that are going to give you a that burst of energy and that burst of pleasure. The more stress, particularly uncontrolled stress you have in your life, the more likely you are to turn to food for emotional relief. So we need a better way to deal with that. one that is more mental, one that is more cognitive based in our thoughts. The best way that I have found to manage this is by doing something called a brain dump, which is the act of just writing everything down that's going on in my brain without judgment,
因此，皮质醇会引发对咸、甜、高脂肪食物的渴望，这些食物能为你带来爆发性的能量和快乐。生活中的压力越大，尤其是无法控制的压力越大，你就越有可能求助于食物来获得情绪上的宣泄。所以我们需要一种更好的方式来处理这个问题，一种更偏向心理层面、基于我们内化思考的方式。我发现管理这一问题的最好方法是进行所谓的“思维大倾倒”（brain dump），也就是把脑海中正在发生的一切毫无保留、
without prejudice, putting those emotions out there. You know, I always say a problem written down is a problem halved. Other ways to manage stress is to find an outlet for that excessive cortisol that is causing you to emotionally eat. because cortisol is really just your body's hormonal response to danger. It's released from our adrenal glands. It's a steroid hormone. It gives you more energy to fight your stresses. It releases more energy for you.
毫无偏见地全部写下来，把那些情绪释放出来。你知道，我常说写下来的问题就等于解决了一半。管理压力的其他方法是为那些导致你情绪性进食的过量皮质醇找到一个宣泄口。因为皮质醇实际上只是你的身体对危险的荷尔蒙反应。它由我们的肾上腺释放。它是一种类固醇激素。它为你提供更多能量来对抗压力。它为你释放更多能量。
So directing that into something that's going to use those sources up, use that excess amount up that's going to make you physically exhausted or mobile is great in those situations. My recent favorite has been box. I cannot shut up about it if you are a close friend of mine. I'm obsessed. I'm addicted. And, you know, there's really nothing like punching a bag over and over again to give yourself an emotional release and to use up that excessive cortisol in your body. But running, cycling, pick your poison. It's all good. But especially if it's aerobic exercise rather than anaerobic exercise, that kind of cardio that's going to get your heart rate up. It's going to allow you to use more energy.
所以把这些能量引导到一些能够消耗掉这些来源、消耗掉过量皮质醇的事情上去，让你在体力上精疲力竭或多活动活动，在这些情况下是非常棒的。我最近最喜欢的是拳击。如果你是我很亲密的朋友，我简直对它赞不绝口。我着迷了，我上瘾了。而且，你知道，没有什么比一遍又一遍地击打沙袋更能让你释放情绪、消耗体内过量皮质醇的了。但是跑步、骑自行车，随你挑什么都行。都挺好的。尤其是进行有氧运动而不是无氧运动，那种能让心率飙升的有氧运动。它能让你消耗更多的能量，
and all of that energy is just energy that's not being placed on your mind, energy that is being released from your body in a positive way. Also, when you know that you're kind of entering into a stressful season or period of life, this may be hard, this may not be something that you feel capable of doing, but I would definitely say reduce how much caffeine you're consuming. Caffeine not only impacts our appetite, but it also makes and heightens those levels of anxiety. I actually no longer drink caffeine at all for that very reason. It just made me so much more stressed. Even though it would increase my focus and concentration,
所有这些能量都不会积压在你的脑海中，而是以一种积极的方式从你的身体中释放出来。另外，当你发现自己即将进入一段压力重重的时期或生活阶段时（这可能很难，可能不是你觉得自己有能力做到的事），但我绝对会建议你减少咖啡因的摄入量。咖啡因不仅会影响我们的食欲，还会加剧和提高焦虑水平。其实我现在为了这个原因，已经完全不喝咖啡因了。它只会让我感到更大的压力。尽管它能提高我的注意力和专注力，
you know, it also meant that I wasn't in control of my energy levels. And I would plummet or I would be either too high or too low. I'd need to eat food to kind of bring me back in the middle. And nowadays, I don't find myself as depleted at the end of the day. Needing that sugar rush, that, you know, that fat rush, that carb brush, that carb brush to push me back up. I can kind of listen to my body bender rather than trying to use something external to release or heighten or decrease my emotions. The next trigger I think most associated with emotional eating is boredom. You know, when you're having a little lazy day
你知道，这也意味着我无法控制自己的能量水平。我会直线下降，要么处于亢奋状态，要么处于低谷。我需要吃东西来把我拉回到中间状态。如今，我发现自己在一天结束时不再那么精疲力竭了。不需要靠糖分、脂肪、碳水化合物来把我的状态重新推高。我可以更好地倾听身体的声音，而不是试图利用外部事物来释放、提升或降低我的情绪。我认为与情绪性进食最相关的下一个触发因素是无聊。你知道，当你度过一个懒散的居家日子，
at home and you keep opening the fridge, closing it, opening the pantry, you're not really hungry, right? You're just wanting something to do. That might seem innocuous, but that is emotional eating. Eating in response to your emotional state, that being boredom. Food is a way to occupy your time and your mind. So instead of needing to find excitement in food, in taste, in flavor, look externally for something to do. Go for a nice long walk. Call a friend you haven't spoken to in a while. That is always so lovely. Do some life admin. Whatever it may be, I think it's important. Obviously, if you want a snack, go for it. But what we want to break here is this cycle of disrupting our natural hunger for emotional hunger.
不断地打开冰箱、关上，打开食品储藏室，你其实并不饿，对吧？你只是想找点事做。这看起来似乎无伤大雅，但这确实是情绪性进食。为了应对你的情绪状态（即无聊）而进食。食物成了打发时间和大脑的一种方式。因此，与其在食物、滋味和风味中寻找刺激，不如去外部寻找点事做。去散个长步。给一个很久没联系的朋友打个电话。那总是非常美好。处理一些生活杂务。无论那是什么，我认为这都很重要。显然，如果你想吃零食，那就去吃吧。但我们想要打破的是这种用情绪饥饿打断自然饥饿的循环。
And boredom can really interrupt that relationship and those cues that we receive from our body. If you're exhausted, take a nice bath, put on some candles. If you're lonely, engage in some nostalgic TV shows or movies, you have no idea how comforting that is. And just realize that you do have the agency and the mental strength to regulate your own emotions in a way that feels healthy, in a way that feels good. for you. Secondly, to identify those triggers, we need to be curious. If I'm not eating for hunger, what am I feeling here? And understanding the why, why am I feeling that? And why do I feel compelled to eat when I might not necessarily want to in this moment? So I would say time is really important here. Pause when those cravings hit and ask yourself, could I put off eating for five or
而无聊确实会打断这种关系以及我们从身体接收到的信号。如果你筋疲力尽，就泡个舒服的热水澡，点上几根蜡烛。如果你感到孤独，去看一些怀旧的电视剧或电影，你绝对想象不到这有多么抚慰人心。只要意识到你确实拥有自主权和心理力量，能够以一种健康、对你感觉良好的方式来调节自己的情绪。其次，为了识别这些触发因素，我们需要保持好奇心。如果我不是因为饥饿而进食，我在这里究竟感受到了什么？去理解这个“为什么”：我为什么会有这种感觉？为什么在此时此刻我可能并不一定想吃的时候，却感到不得不吃？所以我想说时间在这里非常重要。当渴望袭来时，暂停一下，问问自己：我能把进食推迟5到
10 minutes. Is it real hunger that I'm experiencing? Is this mental or physical? And you make the decision from there. It's okay to appreciate the impact that food has on your mood because it's a scientific one that serves a purpose. And to hold off completely, like we said, starts a pretty severe cycle of restricting. So savor don't consume. When we emotionally eat, we tend to do so very quickly and sometimes without even tasting the food. But by slowing down, A, we learn not to fear the feelings that make us want to emotionally eat and just enjoy food when we want it. Food is not something that is on a pedestal.
10分钟吗？我经历的是真正的饥饿吗？这是心理上的还是生理上的？然后从那里做出决定。懂得欣赏食物对你情绪的影响是没问题的，因为这是一门有目的的科学。而完全克制自己，正如我们所说，会开启一个相当严重的限制循环。所以，要品味，而不是吞咽。当我们情绪性进食时，我们往往会吃得非常快，有时甚至连食物的滋味都没尝出来。但通过放慢速度，A，我们学会了不再恐惧那些让我们想要情绪性进食的感觉，并在想吃的时候好好享受食物。食物并不是高高在上的东西，
Food is not something that you're not allowed to have. And B, it actually allows us to listen to physical hunger instead of emotional hunger. Also, eating a nutrient-dense quality diet has associations with minimizing our risk of some of those mental health effects and experiences that we are trying to regulate with food. So there was a 2019 study that showed eating a greater variety of nutrients and vitamins is associated with a better mood, reduced risk of depression, and a lot of other benefits. Food is fuel, food is energy, food is a resource, it's not something that A needs to control you, B needs to be restricted, or C needs to play any other part in life.
食物不是你被禁止食用的东西。B，它实际上能让我们倾听身体的饥饿感，而不是情绪上的饥饿感。此外，遵循营养丰富的高质量饮食习惯，有助于将我们试图用食物来调节的某些心理健康影响和经历的风险降到最低。2019年的一项研究表明，摄入更多样化的营养素和维生素与更好的情绪、降低抑郁风险以及许多其他益处息息相关。食物是燃料，食物是能量，食物是一种资源，它不是那种 A 需要控制你、B 需要被限制、或 C 需要在生活中扮演其他任何角色的东西。
There's also been a lot of buzz recently behind this idea of intuitive eating. And honestly, I wasn't sure whether to talk about this because at first glance, I was kind of like, is this just another fad diet? You know, especially when Gwyneth Paltrow is a big proponent, I'm a little bit skeptical. But I did my research and I do think it's really valuable to speak on because for some it is a solution. It treats food the way that I think a lot of us should be treating. it and it does move us towards a better relationship with what we eat. So intuitive eating, the key principles of this is basically kind of the antithesis of restrictive consumption.
最近，关于“直觉饮食”（intuitive eating）这个概念也有很多讨论。说实话，我不确定是否应该谈论这个，因为乍一看，我有点觉得：这不又是另一种跟风的减肥法吗？特别是当格温妮丝·帕特朗（Gwyneth Paltrow）成为大肆宣扬的代表时，我难免有点怀疑。但我做了研究，我确实认为谈论这个非常有价值，因为对某些人来说，这确实是一个解决方案。它对待食物的方式正是我认为我们许多人应该对待它的方式，并且它确实引导我们与所吃的食物建立起更好的关系。因此，直觉饮食的关键原则基本上就是限制性饮食的反面。
It's about rejecting the diet mentality, which we ate plus for that, big tick of approval, honoring your hunger, once again important when we're trying to counter emotional eating, feeling your fullness, respecting your body, treating it with kindness and compassion and not shame. It's really about eating according to the cues that your body is giving you and about what it needs and wants rather than according to your emotions, to some deeper perspective on what you should be eating. If your body wants carbs, give it carbs. If it wants a big old salad, give it salad. Go for it. Have some sugar. Have some salt. All of those things we've been told to avoid for some misinformed reason have a place, but it's about balance, it's about once again being intuitive.
它是关于拒绝饮食心态的（对此我们点赞加粗，大加赞赏），倾听你的饥饿感（这在我们要对抗情绪性进食时同样重要），感受你的饱腹感，尊重你的身体，以善意和同情心而不是羞耻感对待它。这实际上是根据你的身体给你的信号、根据它的需求和渴望来进食，而不是根据你的情绪，或是关于你应该吃什么的某种更深层的看法。如果你的身体想吃碳水，就给它碳水。如果它想吃一大盘沙拉，就给它沙拉。去吧。吃点糖，吃点盐。所有这些我们因某种被误导的原因而被告知要避免的东西其实都有其一席之地，但这全在于平衡，再次强调，这在于遵循直觉。
I think one of the major benefits, according to some studies published in the National Library of Medicine, is intuitive eating is just somewhat better for our psychological well-being, because we're eating in accordance to our biological urges and what is natural for us, rather than according to something that a diet is trying to tell us to do or to kind of the rollercoaster of our emotions. People experience fewer amounts. fewer levels of food guilt or shame. They have improved body image. But to eat intuitively, you really need to relearn the distinction that we've been saying this whole time. Physical hunger and emotional hunger. You need to trust that feedback loop between your stomach and your brain,
我认为根据国家医学图书馆（National Library of Medicine）发表的一些研究，其中一个主要好处是，直觉饮食对我们的心理健康要好一些，因为我们是根据我们的生理冲动和对我们来说自然的东西来进食，而不是根据某种饮食法试图告诉我们去做的事情，或者是我们情绪过山车的起伏。人们会经历更少程度的食物内疚或羞耻感。他们改善了身体形象。但要做到直觉饮食，你真的需要重新学习我们一直在说的区别：生理饥饿和情绪饥饿。你需要信任你的胃和大脑之间的反馈回路，
because our bodies have an exceptional, finely tuned way of telling us what we need nutritionally, biologically, hunger-wise, rather than just emotionally. And what's really happening, I'm going to say it one more time, when we emotionally eat, we no longer see food as fuel, we see it as a way to regulate our emotions to make us feel better, but only temporarily, only in the moment. I want to finish of this episode by just restating a few key points here. Firstly, emotional eating does not make you a bad person. it does not make you faulty and of course it's subjective as to whether you think that's a problem for you.
因为我们的身体有一种卓越的、微调的方式来告诉我们我们在营养、生理和饥饿方面真正需要什么，而不仅仅是情绪上的需求。真正发生的事情是（我要再说一遍）：当我们情绪性进食时，我们不再把食物视为燃料，而是把它看作是一种调节情绪、让自己感觉更好的方法，但这只是暂时的，只在当下起作用。我想通过重申几个关键点来结束这一集。首先，情绪性进食并不意味着你是一个坏人。它并不意味着你有缺陷，当然，这是否是一个问题因人而异。
Sometimes what we think we are controlling is emotional eating when really it's just actually restriction and avoidance. If you find your behavioral intentions towards food or about controlling your calories or your weight, that I think is more in response to diet culture than I think emotional eating. I think that emotional eating is only part of the problem there because you, you have been restricting yourself too much, avoiding it too much, that food has now been put on this pedestal such that when your emotions are heightened, you are more inclined to go for them because you have less impulse control. Secondly, this is obviously just my advice and my perspective on this and my research.
有时我们以为自己在控制的情绪性进食，实际上只是一种克制和逃避。如果你发现自己对食物的行为意图是关于控制卡路里或体重，我认为这更多是对饮食文化的反应，而不是情绪性进食。我认为情绪性进食只是其中的一部分问题，因为你对自己限制得太多、逃避得太多，以至于食物现在被高高捧起，当你的情绪高涨时，你更有倾向去吃它们，因为你的冲动控制力变弱了。其次，这显然只是我的建议、我的观点以及我的研究。
There are different perspectives and different opinions. And you have agency when it comes to decisions you want to make towards your diet and how you process your emotions. But I do think that we can benefit from feeling like we are in control of our behaviors, whether that has to do with eating or exercise or spending or self-destructive behaviors, whatever it may be, you are in control of them. We do not want food to feel like it controls us. And like we have no power to stop or to start.
会有不同的观点和不同的意见。当你对自己的饮食做出决定以及如何处理自己的情绪时，你拥有自主权。但我确实认为，如果我们能觉得自己掌控了自己的行为（无论这与饮食、运动、消费还是自毁行为有关，无论是什么），我们就能从中受益。我们不希望食物让我们觉得它在控制我们。让我们觉得没有力量去停止或开始。
And thirdly, I just sincerely hope that you enjoyed this episode and that you feel informed. I think these things are rarely spoken about in a modern day culture that is obsessed with things like diets and fads and right or right. wrong and weight loss and calories. Our relationship with food is so much more psychological than we think. And I hope that that comes across and that you're able to look at your own eating habits and see when you're responding to emotional hunger instead of physical hunger. And if you want to make a choice around that, be, have the agency, have the information to be able to do that. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I really do hope that you enjoyed it. this is something I'm learning with you. I find that talking about this is so interesting when I talk
第三，我由衷地希望你喜欢这一集，并且觉得有所收获。我认为在这样一个痴迷于饮食、跟风、对错、减肥和卡路里的现代文化中，这些事情很少被讨论。我们与食物的关系比我们想象的要心理化得多。我希望这一点能够传达给你，让你能够审视自己的饮食习惯，看看自己在什么时候是为了应对情绪饥饿而不是生理饥饿。如果你想围绕这一点做出选择，请拥有自主权，拥有能够做到这一点的资讯。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真的希望你们能喜欢。这是我和你们一起在学习的课题。我发现和朋友家人聊起这个话题非常有趣，
about it with friends and family. And you really do examine how mental your dietary habits are. It's something that I think I've been learning the better my relationship with food has become. So I hope that you got something out of this. I hope you enjoyed it. As always, please give us a follow if you want to be notified when new episodes come out. Please also feel free to leave a five-star review wherever you get your podcast if you're listening on Spotify. on Apple, Google Podcasts, whatever your cup of tea is, please feel free to give us a five-star review and give us a follow at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. If you have an episode suggestion, you just want to see some behind-the-scenes content, some video clips. We've got it
你真的会去审视你的饮食习惯中包含了多少心理因素。随着我和食物的关系变得越来越好，我一直在学习这方面的知识。所以我希望你从中学到东西，希望你喜欢它。一如既往，如果你想在新节目发布时收到通知，请关注我们。如果你是在 Apple、Google Podcasts 或任何你喜欢的平台上收听，也请随时在你获取播客的地方留下五星好评，并在 Instagram 上关注 That Psychology Podcast。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想看一些幕后花絮和视频片段，我们在那里应有尽有。
all over there. So we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我们下周会带着另一集回归。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO percent。
On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。对1979年来说，那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。还有我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite. favorite therapist and hosts care games.
比如谈论80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《从头学起》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。